Bộ xây dựng để bảo đam ăn toàn hàng không và phòng người ở các sự cú tình tự
Cú khoang không Việt Nam phải khẩn trường thiết lập kênh lạch chính thức.
Phuối hợp với nhà trước trách nhiều chà sự cú, phọng tay nạn tổ bài của đất
và các cú coa liên quan cú đựng yêu cầu nằm bắt thông tin,
tham gia của chính điều chà theo quy định và kịp thời báo gáo kích qua điều chà của nhà trước trách đất
cùng các biển pháp khóc phục phòng người ở sự cú,
để cạnh đó, cú khoang không Việt Nam cần tăng cường giám sát ăn toàn
đối pháp đậm hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình
Khai thác và bảo giữa tổ bài của các hàng hàng không Việt Nam
đối với Việt Nam Airlines Bộ xây dựng yêu cầu hàng
phối hợp trách trách sẽ với nhà trước trách đều chà của đất
nhà sản xuất tổ bài và nhà sản xuất động cơ để phục phụ của ua chình đều chà
làm giọng của nhà sự cú, theo báo gáo về nằm Airlines chuyển bài bên ở bà
mấy thứ tự biểu nịch về hà nội, các cạnh lúc mời bà dờ
hình hình hình hình thống xuất hiện cạnh báo liên quan việc đối mài bài
và quên đường bằng và a sức lúc, tổ lai thông báo cho kiểm soát
viên không liều sau đó quy định quay lại sợ bài miều nịch để kiểm tra ký thuật
bài bài hạn cạnh an toàn tọn bộ hai chăm mởi mốt hình khách và mời sảo thành viên
tổ bài được đưa xuống phằng xây thang